there was a Democratic presidential
debate last night did you even know that
nobody here knew that it's that's crazy
right I had a debate last night to see
who will be the Democratic candidate for
president right nobody here and we get a
very savvy crowd just kidding it's
mostly convicts this true story there
was a debate last night did you watch it
I thought I did watch a little bit of
but I had watched eleven hours of the
you know yeah yeah I mean so it's broke
yeah check this out this is a true story
last night's you shouldn't feel bad
about not seeing cuz last night's
democratic debate was the least watched
democratic debate yet yes yeah true
story the ratio was one viewer for every
one candidate only 35 people wide and 35
debated yeah you know who's not happy
oh right now thanks a lot any that
you're welcome why don't you do that
more off we've been doing this 26 years
you've never helped me out that way you
know who else Oh Andrew yang supporters
are not happy Andrew yang supporters are
angry that their candidate didn't get to
talk very much last night yeah
and Joe Biden supporters are angry that
there's did
that was a crisp burst of laughter that
cut off eerily fast
well had people at home were gonna think
that was fake during last night's
Democratic presidential debate the
candidates discussed childcare that was
one of the big issues was childcare
Bernie Sanders said his kids don't need
childcare because they're all in their
late 60s for elder care who are you
gonna vote for the hope from a dad